watching the American media's coverage
of the g7 and Biarritz France I can't
help but think they can't go any lower
or be more uninformed or more dishonest
what if anything do you think the
president accomplished at this g7 summit
well it's not clear anything really
isolated and alone on the world stage
the president wasn't leading at this g7
summit but he was misleading it's more
less of a g7 and more of a kind of g6
plus-one Oh brilliant analysis the
indisputable fact is that America under
President Trump has an economy that is
the envy of the world did kill for the
numbers we have yet is if on cue the
press finds a way to frame things in the
worst possible light against Trump but
here's what you need to know number one
China is coming back to the trade
negotiating table that's all because of
Trump's tariffs number two the White
House in Japan are negotiating a new
trade deal on agriculture and beef it's
going to be great for American farmers
number three the UK wants a trade deal
well they're gonna have to wait after
the brexit deal is settled to get it
number four the EU is facing huge
political and economic problems and
number five we have the strongest
economy bar none in the g7 yet Peter
Baker a pundit masquerading as a
journalist at the New York Times he was
so desperate to hit trop that he
measured the meeting success on the
number of words in the final statement
that came out for the g7 quote with all
the differences with Trump the g7
leaders ended up releasing a largely
general one-page statement that added up
to 264 words the last joint statement
under Obama in 2016 was fourteen
thousand two hundred and sixty three
words international bureaucrats they
they talk a lot and write a lot
meaningless blather
that was back in 2016 of course when the
US economy was kind of limping along and
China was eating our lunch yes that you
want that or do you want a short g7
statement as we enjoy unparalleled
economic success especially compared to
the French the Germans and the British
my friends this is an easy call the fact
that major European countries are an
economic turmoil it's not our fault it's
theirs they stake their futures on a
European Union that was flawed from the
inception they were over regulating
their businesses and over taxing their
people and they allowed in more than a
million refugees of very different
backgrounds and different values and yet
the media they somehow think Trump
should follow their lead I don't think
so
Trump had the guts to do a serious
review and revision of previous
administration I'm talking both parties
their disastrous trade policy with China
China has taken a very hard hit over the
last number of months now they've lost
three million jobs it'll soon be much
more than three million jobs their chain
is breaking the prayer chain is breaking
up like nobody's seen before and once
that happens it's very hard to put it
back together you understand I think
they want very much want to make a deal
and the longer they wait the harder it
is to put it back the president is being
very crafty here the media is not gonna
give him any credit and very pragmatic
he's still willing to work a deal with
the Chinese yet he's not going to agree
to anything if it returns the United
States to the status quo before he came
into office where China just cheated
rampantly and they got stronger and
stronger at our expense year after year
after year he's not gonna agree to that
yet in the framing again of every story
CNN MSNBC etc are essentially taking the
word of this oppressive communist
government over that of their own
countries president bean even gone too
far for C NBC's Jim Cramer
I think you have to take him seriously
because he can walk back anything he
says and you know you could have the
Chinese officially denying the Chinese
haven't necessarily been Square and
honest heaven means something we believe
the Chinese are honest because we're did
so many people would rather take the
word of the Chinese Communist Party the
knocker guy really guessed that we trust
the PRC more than we trust the White
House I love Joe Kernan he was making a
point with a laugh there but it's a
serious one
now forget what you think of Trump style
or tweets or the way you dress is
whatever it is look at the results we
have yellow vests protests in France we
have the ongoing brexit drama
we have Italy's government in complete
chaos meltdown Germany headed or already
in a recession
my friends Europe is in chaos and yet
the EU attempt at managing democratic
socialism we see it's failed miserably
now remember that Obama the darling of
the media elites the global media elites
he tried his best to push a European
style agenda here in the United States
and that worked out so well that he
ended up turning over the White House to
Donald Trump people don't want any part
of it and yet it's insanity the
Democrats are doubling down on socialism
in this new election in 2020 and they're
really marketing this madness to our
youth and they will do to America what
the EU has done to Europe zero growth a
destroyed and demoralized middle class
and yet somehow the media will again
miss the real story and that's the angle